the mandalorian season two episode two
can't wait to watch this today am i
right
[Laughter]
i hope you're just as gentle with a real
child someday
why would you say that first things
first reject nation make sure to
subscribe and click that notification
bell so you get notified when our next
amanda
reaction is up secondly full length
reaction watch alongs where you sync up
with the time code for mandalorian or
over at our patreon page this qualifies
as reaction highlights and over at our
patreon we cover so many shows
we're at the same tier we have the
option for reaction highlights and
watch-alongs included some of those
shows are supernatural
doctor who jojo's bizarre adventure
attack on titan my hero academia
recently started up avatar the last
airbender demon slayer and a whole bunch
of other television shows lastly
gotta thank eric over at nerd chronic
for editing this video for us
mandalorian can often present itself
with some issues of getting public on
youtube
and he's really great at working around
whatever best options we got to get us
up in a timely manner
so thank you for all the hard work you
do buddy give him a follow today to me
he's a is an extension of the real
rejects
let's watch this
very cool
wow you avoided a lot of damage there
didn't jar oh
his name is baby yoda
nice don't you
wait
drop the knife you literally really let
him take it
uh he's gonna shoot that guy
even better
[Laughter]
is he's got a little more hair right
yeah lego he's got a little bit more
hair on his head a little peach fuzz
there yeah baby yoda peach fuzz
no no why he's gonna try and eat him
i think he can sense the life in them i
hope you're right
or maybe you're right
[Laughter]
we will sit place your bets in the
comments below
it's got a real spielberg vibe going on
with him right now
no no no no no oh no
the music threw me for a loop it's just
such a sense of wonder
hey you almost talked me out like no
yeah i want to believe you just
i need you to send us a pin i know this
voice
well i'm not sure i have that heart to
be felonies i assume every mysterious
cameo is day flawed
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
hey i was over here being like is this
brad pitt joseph gordon
oh yeah get those get those aerial crash
zooming pans
jesus
man this is shot so wow
don't make us do it i can't wait to play
this ride at disneyland
did you turn your beacon off
oh no oh golly
oh no
oh buddy those eggs should be in the
cockpit
[Music]
i told you not to do that
maybe you shouldn't keep the eggs there
yeah with baby yoda
maybe you shouldn't keep them just like
stray in a hallway
this theme is about parenting
i guess those are just stories
[Laughter]
where are you going come back here
i said hey hey hey
i said hey what's going on
don't hit me maybe oh
quickly before you missed the whole show
oh god where did i miss
the child how's he holding on
mirror this exactly
this is a shadow cast right now and
you're
you playing leave the ship it's not safe
out here
i'm literally taking a bath my dude i
think she's trying to seduce him
oh my goodness so many eggs
oh she's just bathing her eggs i thought
she produced new eggs
what
you can't just eat everything
god it's like a spider pumpkin
yeah here we go oh
no no it's just going to be a buffet for
him
get out of the bathtub oh
what a dreadful pov that was too
shelob oh
oh what a nightmare
go faster let's go faster
must go faster
[Music]
through the ice oh jesus
eat one dude protect her
oh my god she's she's got a cover yeah
good shot oh
yeah you watched that
this really is like
a sci-fi horror movie right now yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh
eat them all no
unhand the child
light laser shots
oh my gosh
egg this looks like a lovecraftian
monster my god
who is that are they the x-wings back
yes we ran the tabs on the razor crest
am i under arrest technically you should
be
but these are trying times
like i'm gonna be a badass this season
all right sick of these little cameos
damn we forgot to lift the giant spider
off
oh man though
golly
[Music]
so is he like safe now i f that's the
sense i got was it was one of those like
we're just not gonna report this to
anybody
we'll at least help you to not die and
we'll call it even
yeah or or at least yeah we'll we'll
just not
it's probably that the warrant still
exists but they're not going to say
anything in true
old west fresh like
yeah i could help you but you know
i really did have like a throwback
sci-fi noir
yeah uh stranded alien-esque vibe to it
it's real
especially and in the way too it starts
very much in one place and kind of
morphs into something else
entirely it's a terrible episode
yeah man didn't get many reactions out
of me
didn't uh think very much of it
that was great i think we're safe to cut
it now
that was a cool episode i really like
the tone of it i kind of like the
meditative pace of it all
it's not that slow it's not that
deliberate i do think though in
comparison to episodes that have come
before this one
its pacing is a lot more deliberate
comparatively speaking
but it's not like better call saul or
something like that you know
two though it's also got the expanded
run time because i feel like the first
season there were a couple episodes that
breached that 40 or even an hour mark
but a lot of them were like a half hour
whereas you know we started off with an
hour last week and then you know a solid
40 like a normal length of a show and i
feel like part of that is to kind of
help with that sort of you're just
right there in his shoes kind of pacing
yeah and it's a very
oh for a star wars show it surprisingly
feels rather contained in a certain
extent
it picks up immediately after the first
episode so the hunt for
the child is being re-established again
and that was a really
fun sequence i like going to the cantina
pale motto and then
ant-man character guys i don't know what
creature that is i'm sure it's the star
wars creature i'm not familiar with that
one um maybe
from the books or something but i'm not
familiar with that one but either way if
i think if you know who's directing this
episode one's mine will probably go
there and like ours did you know this a
simple plot
of having to transport this person it's
set in its upper segway into
episode three where hopefully we see
more mandalorians i mean that's what
we've been building up to since the
beginning of this particular season i
like
whatever that ice planet is the the
sequence there
does feel kind of reminiscent of the
mood and tone of alien i mean you called
it right away with the eggs
i mean they're smaller than the face
huggers in the alien movie but the way
that it was all
unfolding was
yeah these will get big eventually
there's a big one
they're all gonna hatch and it does have
that vibe and there were parts of that
ice planet that did remind me
a little bit of um the sequences in
empire strikes back not just because
it's an ice planet like hoth but you
know like thinking about when luke is
stranded when luke is captured and
they're like these cave-like
environments those things were
bringing me back to empire strikes back
the thing that i loved most about peyton
reed's direction here
was the handling of perspective that
created the most amount of tension i
thought for
for me of especially really throwing you
into mando's shoes like when he's behind
the wheel of the razor crest the x-wing
pilots show up
space cops are right there and the way
how you're not you don't cut to
dave filoni and i forgive me for not
knowing the other actor's name but you
don't cut to those pilots
until after mando takes off so you're
watching it solely from his perspective
having to lie his way through here i
thought it was interesting too when he
said
may the force be with you he had this
kind of uncomfortable cadence in his
tone about it
like him saying that is obviously not a
natural thing and it had me
thinking because the way how season one
ended it seemed like he didn't really
have much familiarity with what the
force is
it could be the most tiny detail i'm
reading into
of his delivery thinking about like a
new hope and though
and the way how the new republic that's
just the thing they say you know instead
of peace be with you
or you know like take care yeah safety
travels it's may the force move with you
it definitely felt like one of those
things that he's aware of but he's not
used
enough to lying about well yeah i'm i'm
thinking that it might
be a little bit of an additional world
building in the tiniest bit of ways
of it's a saying that everyone knows but
not everyone is really all that familiar
with
the force itself yeah and so i feel like
it might be reading it's about i don't
know
i'm probably just really reading into an
actor's delivery here
the space hunt sequence leading into the
planet was shot beautifully
where i'm a little bit torn as much as i
like anything with horror addition
i really love automatically i'm just a
sucker for that
and again with perspective like when
you're following them back into the
cockpit of the razor's crest
the blasts are coming you're not cutting
to outside till mando's outside
and then when he comes back through the
the ship and it's covered in spider webs
and all these things
it was really well shot and the
production design was great and i love
its attention to detail on practical
effects
and the cgi was awesome too the monsters
were pretty scary i guess like the one
thing that's kind of not making this a
a like a 10 out of 10 for me the
anxiousness side in me
of it's only eight episodes you know the
first episode i
really did love it was very exciting to
me i'm getting that anxiety feeling
of come on let's get to all the stuff
you know
we we told we're like hyped up about or
all the cliffhanger stuff we've been
wanting you know and i remember
i remember with the first season in the
first few episodes
there was a debate kind of happening
with some fans like people were
generally loving it but there was that
debate happening of
are these just one officers that's
really going somewhere where this is all
going to coalesce and tie together even
with having a bit of that feeling for
this particular episode of
come on let's go i still have complete
faith that
this will this even this episode will
somehow leap into
the bigger picture of the story being
told in season two
yeah i mean i'm funny enough i'm kind of
in the opposite position where i'm
actually quite thrilled that they
haven't just like rocketed forward into
like some big wide expanse of like okay
we gotta get all this stuff we've been
hyping you up for
like i loved that this episode didn't
have any boba fett in it like it was
cool we'll tease that we'll bring it
back later what struck me during this
episode what i realized and it's just
like a simple summation of how the show
tends to operate is yeah every
next step of the serial story kind of
has to come with
an episodic bounty scenario or safe
passage scenario or some kind of
side quest because you know he can't
just hop around
necessarily at will the way they do in
the movies and stuff like that so you
know just having that
sort of like okay well the next cluster
mandalorians i need to get to is on the
other side of
this journey you know like yeah i don't
know i i can understand why
you would be a bit nervous because yeah
now thinking of it i'm like we are a
quarter of the way into the season now
i wouldn't say i'm nervous i'm just
anxious that's it
that's that's the only thing that it's
playing on like that
anxiousness has actually nothing to do
with the criticism
of the episode executed before me it's
really just
me being like oh i want to do it
part of it for me too is i get so lost
in the charm of the fact that the show
does
feel very it's funny i think you
you're right in describing this episode
as feeling contained but what i love
that the mandalorian as opposed to
especially like the recent film
run has been able to do is they're able
to make things feel contained
and grounded but still very big and very
awe
inspiring yeah cause like the whole
thing on that ice planet is like yeah
this is like
very restricted in a lot of ways and
it's you're just in ice tunnels and ice
caves but at the same time
we're seeing a new creature and the just
the tension
with which like props to peyton reed
because i found myself just getting
wrapped up in the tension and how
gross certain things were they didn't
feel like the director of ant-man didn't
know
i didn't yeah i didn't expect to be so
like oh my god yeah
during this it was tense believe it or
not i mean other than that i feel like
that statement i was making earlier it
could be wildly misconstrued why do you
hate the show no because i actually
completely agree with you i love that
they have this much attention to detail
in terms of they're taking advantage of
the fact that it's a series they're
bound to be hunted down and they're bad
this adds more to that that
they're bound to crash at some point it
has to go through ship repairs this is a
likely scenario he has to still make
money he has to get his information he
has to trade missions and deals and
everything
in order to keep going it makes it feel
more lived-in
so i actually really do love it i'm
wondering how this particular episode
will tie into the bigger picture
and i even like the the chat with the
x-wing pilots how
you know i think the bounties they were
talking about were the ones
linked with the one where zero appeared
uh with like the one with bill byrne and
all that
i think those were the bounties they
were referring to episode six
i believe is what it was tying all this
back into it and helping to flesh it all
out i even like frog lady
yeah yeah and i don't know what her i
don't know what a creature is but you
know if you guys know what a creature is
let me know frog lady
creature i can't find the answer
mystery is still to come in the star
wars universe yeah we don't know maybe
she's a
secret relative of young yoda i like how
you can get inv even though it's the
only time you know what she's really
saying is either through translation of
moto
or through um the droid it's the zero
droid you have this character of
denjarin
whose face you can't see who were very
emotionally invested into then you got
this frog lady character who most of the
time we don't understand
yet we're very invested in her too so
the danger of the stakes that were
coming in with the spiders
was my concern for her and i found like
i'm really nervous
for what's going to happen to her and
that's where all the fear came from
because
but man doing baby yoda i was like i
don't know nothing's going to happen on
them it's still intense but i know
nothing's really going to happen to them
but for her i was worried about it baby
yoda i don't really know what they're
what it's like a i was like i'm not
finding this whole eating the eggs thing
all that adorable
no the way they have this button i got
another one
there's something about that like that
that's a little thing and it's not quite
clicking with me because i'm like the
whole point of liberty's freaking eggs
yeah i mean i wonder what the bigger
picture of that is but it is one of
those kind of like oh
you know i think partly probably they're
like well he can't just be adorable and
helpful at all times
and b i wonder if this will you know
come up later
sure other things he might want to try
and eat that
you shouldn't eat uh but you know as as
one of many things to worry about in
this episode they didn't have to do that
but i wasn't upset that they did and i
think maybe also they were like and this
will give us a direct device to help
them wake up sure
or whatever you okay
i'm just so choked up by how beautiful
this is
but yeah too like this really reminded
me heavily of all the western stuff what
misses me from the movies is like
it's usually we get to the destination
and then something goes wrong whereas
this feels like
on our way to the destination a bunch of
unexpected things are going to happen
and they're going to be things like we
can't quite communicate or maybe
random kind of space cops who are sort
of neutral in our situation are gonna
show up and those things
i think two can be sort of viewed as
pedestrian in a way but to me they're
part of the the
tangibility in the western charm of the
show yeah and i loved how
kind of grouchy mando was in his house
grumpy yeah like beginning to end
like i'm so annoyed by everything and
like i don't want to fix the [ __ ] we're
going to stay here
nobody held up to the deal nobody
presented this
with honesty that just seemed so
stressed
and he's having to learn how to parent
all right guys well mandalorian season
two episode two would you guys think of
the
the passenger episode leave your
thoughts down below subscribe click that
notification bell
last but not least let's do up
jason dolan i'm gonna shout out your
home girl again for you buddy
cazzy reacts jason edits for her and i
believe
she's already started covering
mandalorian season two recently put up
her reactions for
mandalorian season one joker movie
reaction you might have seen us
mention that on our youtube community
page she does a wonderful job
great personality some of the most
genuine sometimes
really funny reactions she gets so
emotionally invested in everything she's
watching and her mandalorian reactions i
saw a few of them for season one are
pretty great so if you're a fan of the
mandalorian
i think you're gonna want to go check
out her channel jason edits for her
essentially the producer of the channel
as well so
jason keep up the good work shouts out
to kazzy as well
hope you guys are doing okay talk to you
guys soon
[Music]
you